wenn stars es gehört zu den härtesten
gefängnisse in england und hier sitzt
boris becker jetzt ein nur vier
kilometer trennen ihn von wimbledon der
ort den er immer als sein wohnzimmer
bezeichnet
sein neues zuhause kalt karg gefährlich
knapp 1600 männer sind inhaftiert die
wärter gelten als knallharte es gibt
fünf flügel jeder flügel hat eigene
duschen und eine kantine
die zellen sind eine mischung aus
einzel- und mehr bezahlen besonders
schaurig nur dieser knast in england hat
noch immer einen funktionsfähigen galgen
obwohl die todesstrafe längst
abgeschafft wurde er dient zur
abschreckung
doch das gefängnis ist nicht nur
deswegen berüchtigt diverse promis
reihen sich in die geschichte der
häftlinge ein so saß wikileaks gründer
julian assange hier seine strafe ab er
berichtet später von pädophilen die die
ganze nacht lauthals von ihren taten
erzählen
auch der legendäre schriftsteller oskar
wald und rock api d'orsay verbrachten
hier einsame nächte
der britische journalist chris atkins
schreibt nach seinem aufenthalt in
wentworth von miserablen
lebensbedingungen versifften toiletten
und gewalt untereinander auch drogen
seien an der tagesordnung ein kleiner
lichtblick für boris der knallhart knast
bietet yoga kurse gartenarbeit und hat
einen eigenen chor für ein neues hobby
hat borussia jetzt mehr als ein jahr
zeit
[Musik]